it's been quite some time since the
world saw a gi joe adventure on the big
screen
with the dwayne johnson led gi joe
retaliation arriving back in 2013
and making 375 million dollars worldwide
the action thriller wasn't a
disappointment but it also wasn't a
rip-roaring success
so the future of the paramount own
franchise has been uncertain
although a third film titled ever
vigilant is supposedly still in
development but the series is now
pushing forward in a new direction
by fleshing out the origin story of the
team's famed ninja
snake eyes in his own solo origin film
with crazy rich asian star henry golding
leading the film as a titular hero
the movie sure seemed like an easy win
for paramount pictures
snake eyes director robert suenke and
screenwriter evan spiliotopoulos
focus on intense fight scenes in the
film showing what could be done with the
characters in the right hands
the first trailer quickly caught the
attention of many action fans
especially since eko always of the raid
fame plays hardmaster
a key figure in steakhouse backstory
however steak ice has bombed at the box
office
only pulling in 30 million domestically
alongside a measly 4 million dollars
worldwide in the first three days of its
release
so why the poor debut here's why snake
eyes might have flopped so badly at the
box office
after plenty of build up in advance of
the film's release it seems like the
one-two bunch of poor reviews for steak
eyes
alongside growing concerns about the
delta variant of covert 19
has put off potential audiences
currently the solo spin-off is sitting
at a 42
rating on rotten tomatoes alongside a
b-minus on cinema score
so as audiences are cautious about
returning to theaters many fans aren't
going to want to part with their
hard-earned cash
for a movie they'll possibly come away
from feeling shortchanged
what is it you want
i want it all that's basically what box
office pro analyst sean robbins
explained to variety recently
saying movie going and general household
economics are both still in recovery
mode
potential audiences are being selective
with what they spend their money on
it's possible that the film might have
had a better reception if it had debuted
as a rental on a particular streaming
service
but it's also understandable why
paramount chose to stick with a
theatrical release
since snake eyes was already delayed
four times throughout the last year
thanks to the ongoing global situation
there's also the problem of giving a
team player his own adventure
in an attempt to carry a full reboot of
the gi joe franchise
as franchise entertainment research
chief david a gross told variety
when a character is spun off in a
thriller series like this a big drop
follows
gross went on to say demand was simply
limited here especially without a
well-known star or ensemble to drive
interest outside the fanbase
so with franchise fatigue to blame it's
always difficult to find the next big
franchise that will bring audiences to
the movie theater in droves
ever since marvel studios seemingly
cracked the code of what a cinematic
universe can do
many studios have tried replicating the
formula with varying degrees of success
so far gi joe hasn't really managed to
do the same even with its lengthy list
of characters and storylines that
stretch from the animated tv shows and
movies
since there hasn't been a gi joe film
since 2013
audiences have had no real reason to be
truly excited
about a revival of the franchise sure
the heavy focus on impressive stunts and
fights was meant to be the hug for snake
eyes but apparently it isn't enough to
draw movie goers
ultimately it's possible that the
appetite for new shared universe
storytelling is starting to wane
especially in comparison to properties
like those owned by marvel and dc
it's not the first time a studio has
failed to kick-start a new franchise
in recent years a good example is the
infamous dark universe
which pictured a future where all of
universal's monster properties would
converge
but then 2017's the mummy did little to
inspire horror fans
there's also the amazing spider-man
debacle a sony's attempt at creating its
own separate marvel universe of
spidey-related characters faltered
following the poor reception to the
sequel
perhaps the financial and critical
disappointments of snake eyes might
indicate to paramount that it's time to
go back to the intellectual property
mine
to find something else to adapt for the
big screen if you're still curious about
the film
snake ice is in theaters now check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you